four key is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him woody
we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was paper soup salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we gotta get pork of
bourbon
you know these Toy Story movies mean so
much to so many people around the world
was there a moment when you realize that
this wasn't just another movie that your
portrayal of Woody and Buzz had helped
create two of the most iconic characters
we've ever seen on the big screen it
goes back a long way when you realize it
a child who you cannot quite yet read
yet has seen the movie and understands
it's something special about it and is
walking around with a buzz that they do
not let out of their grasp or a woody
that they sleep with every night mostly
buzz come on out sell you I gave you
first role on that a little bit come on
it was right at the very beginning I
would say that the premiere of the first
movie we thought was this gonna work is
anybody gonna care is it just gonna be a
thing and it ended up being something on
a much much higher existential plane
that I always plant right when you see
kids that won't let go of their Woody
doll but they either or Halloween
costumes when I saw all the Halloween
costumes and they were just now I was
waving to a toddler in a in a bus out
with Buzz Lightyear around remai it was
Mickey Mouse I mean that was when I grew
up that that was everywhere from pencil
races to lunchboxes that it was to
become in that world it's a little
humbling to be totally honest with you
but these kids as they said they picked
these boys up and they won't let it go
and friends of mine and my kids go to
school and they it's a bits a bit it
became a big deal so it's humbling
I believe it when people would call up
the number for Fandango and ask for
tickets to the local screening that was
the moment that it really launched off
for me and now we're in Toy Story land
and your voices are blaring back at us
and that's gotta be cool
any Bo Peep you know has she's a badass
adventurer in this movie she's a bit of
an action hero did that evolution of the
character change your approach to her in
any way well yeah she was a little
different I mean it it's been it was
interesting to approach it since we
started this 25 years ago but yeah I was
really happy to see how
evolved and grown and gotten old
courageous and fierce and just how women
ought to be and when they asked you to
come back and play such a significant
role in this film was that was it was
that exciting did you jump out the
opportunity you know I I really when I
began again I I didn't know the size of
it because I I never saw the script so
it was kind of like week by week is like
oh that's nice that's wow that's fun
so it was it was kind of a revealed to
me slowly but I'm thrilled with the
result well it's great and she's amazing
in the film too Tony are you ready for
the forty fandom because like my kids
the character they care most about is
for ki and it's a spork and it's crazy
to believe but you know for ki is a
character made from trash so what's your
approach to it did you look did anything
or anyone inspire your performance I'm
40 I was very new to the universe I'm is
overwhelmed it's working and I love that
he's always asking questions you know he
sees everything new I love when the toys
all drop down humans walk in he's right
what's going on he doesn't understand
any of the rules and I loved Tony thinks
the movie is called Toy Story I actually
heard a kid yesterday say Toy Story 40
so there is something to that Christina
Gabby Gabby has a bit of a sinister side
to her but she also has this immense
vulnerability was it tricky to tow that
line I mean
normally Allah frightened no she she has
a goal she knows exactly what she wants
and it's actually a loving goal and it's
it's she wants to fulfill her destiny
she wants to be the best at what she can
be and that's her whole point and if she
has to go about it and a certain way bet
she you know the way that woody finally
gives in to her as she she makes a plea
she makes a plea and says this is this
is real and I need it and he understands
it because they're one in the same in a
way and I think it's quite sweet
they were the creepy puppets that are
your kind of creepy Keano did you ever
have a creepy toy when you were growing
up that that you didn't play with
because it would creep you out too much
no but I but I did have the like the
scary ventriloquist doll kind of thing
yeah well I've got the fear of you know
like the ventriloquist the doll in your
room and you keep it in a closet or
something like that that face that grin
looking down at you is it trying all
these and I have one and when I went to
go when they showed me Gabby Gabby and
they were like and this is it I was like
but I actually go to antique stores and
I have one of those dolls and I was like
someone did some research Yano do kaboom
a big scene stealer on this film
Canada's greatest stuntman would do
kaboom be a Kara I figure that you would
have had growing up like what were the
toys that you had young Keano had grown
up in his room yeah why not yeah I mean
I had hot real cars I had the track I
had the race cars I had the Train the
Train thing yeah so do kaboom toy would
have been a lot of fun and did you know
did you played a lot of kind of action
heroes how is do kaboom different from
other other action heroes that you
played the body counts not as big yet
yeah I'm not going to ask the John wick
first dude
shows up in John wick for no jolly
kabooms full of love and he's a show man
and he wants to entertain people and he
wants to take risks from people he wants
to entertain Tom this is a very
emotional journey from woody and the
first three films were very emotional
why do you think this one sort of is
stands apart from the rest
what mainly is because woody finds love
and it's a committed love and it's it's
quite stated there's nothing it's time
for beau and woody to cross that river
and enjoy life on the other side of
their toys and at the end of course
Story 3 this thing happened where
they're all about to meet their fiery
doom and what do they do they reach out
for each other which was like which is
like this this this existential moment
of zeitgeist that kind of like broke me
when I saw the end of the movie so to
get it to get into Ford to see that they
are still there that bond never ever
ever goes away and it will not go away
despite the fact that there now is a
union of I'm not going to say mrs. peep
the cowboy but I don't know what Woody's
last name is but now that now that
that's going to be I'm not saying it
happens I'm just saying that there's a
commitment that's made
you